you find all of these
but they're like you know their cards in
your poker hand and you're not sure
where you're going to play them or even
if you're going to play them
when we're developing a character how
much are we charting out
all of sort of the wonderful and
terrible things that have happened to
them
are we doing this beforehand before we
get into the actual story we're kind of
coming up with a checklist
of defining moments
this
um
this is one of
the
confounding
qualities of storytelling
we don't have a linear process
where we do this first and the second we
sort of try we have to have we have to
approach
the story somehow
but i think that what we do is we
i typically have a notion for what is
the story what
maybe in a sentence
what is the story i want to tell
and that tells me something about a
character
and um
and also something about the plot that
is it's somebody like this
trying to
you know climb out of a well and
so
um
but then i go back to the character and
i said well i have more questions for
you character uh where did you come from
how did you get in that well
what were you doing in the field in the
first place
and
um
sometimes the answers are really
surprising to me
sometimes they come as sort of
epiphanies as i'm
out for a run or taking a shower or
lying in bed
often though they come as a result of
just
the ditch digging of sitting and asking
these questions
i know that this person
to be interesting
needs to have
both strength and weakness
when did they discover they had that
strength
when did they first experience
the
crippling quality of that weakness
and um
then i come bring the character back to
the story
and now they're doing more interesting
things that i didn't expect them to do
because there's more
to that character and so i discover more
twists and turns
that are potential within
say the events or the plot of the story
and then i go back to the character so
i'm i think i'm
it's a very messy
uh recursive process
when i am finding these defining moments
for a character i don't know if any of
them will end up on
screen at first i'm just discovering
what are these moments
and then
so there are things i can do with a
defining moment i can just know about it
and it's going to inform how i write
dialogue for this character
other times i'm going to say
if i were writing pixar's finding nemo i
would say
oh that moment when marlin's whole
family gets eaten by a barracuda
i think we should see that
that's really visual and exciting and
tragic
would pixar allow us to start a
children's movie
with
that kind of scene
because if we were to do that
then we would really understand why
marlon is this overprotective father who
won't let
nemo have any adventure have any fun
experience any danger and we won't view
him just as
you know oh that neurotic marlin
uh
we will feel with him well of course he
is a hyper vigilant parent because
this tragedy struck him and we witnessed
it we experienced it with him
now when i first came up with that i
didn't somebody did if i was the one who
had come up with that i
i wouldn't have known at first does that
make it into the movie or not
there are other moments
that we don't see
but a character talks about
they just tell you the story of what
happened or they allude to the story
whatever makes great dialogue
and then other times there are moments
right in the middle of the movie where a
character transforms
and here i think the great example is
michael corleone and
the godfather
so we know that michael is a war hero
just back from world war ii he's
the
son
who was not supposed to get mixed up
with
the family's crime business he was
supposed to go on and maybe be a senator
maybe even a president
but after his
father gets gunned down
michael decides he's got to take matters
into his own hands
and so he goes to meet
the crime boss who had his father gunned
down
and the police captain who protects
that other crime boss because to meet
them at an italian restaurant he has a
gun planted in the bathroom
and
he
excuses himself from the table goes back
to the bathroom gets the gun
and then there's this long pause as
michael
smoothes his hair
and
sort of allows himself to
make his choice
am i going to step across this threshold
from which there can be no return or not
and
then the director has set it up so
michael has to pass through three sets
of doors
as he returns into the restaurant from
the bathroom just to emphasize visually
this is a threshold
there is a
real boundary of before and after here
michael walks out into the restaurant
guns down the police captain and the
other crime boss
and
the rest of the movie and the next movie
and the next movie
the die is cast for all of those
in that moment of
the change of michael's
legal status
from war hero to killer
there's also a moral and a spiritual
change that happens in him
and
he thinks he's done this for all the
best reasons for family
but in the end
he becomes someone who kills
members of his family
for the family
and he is undone
by this action
uh by this choice that he's made in a
moment that defines him
so you find that moment and you think ah
that's probably a scene in the movie and
in fact that becomes
the fulcrum of the whole movie
the moment that
uh
defines michael
as
who will become the godfather
so you you find all of these
but they're like you know their cards in
your poker hand and you're not sure
where you're going to play them or even
if you're going to play them
and that is the messy organic
artistic process i suppose of
crafting a story but you can't craft it
if you don't have the raw materials
from which to craft it and i think that
defining moments are
one of those
really rich materials that
we have to work with when we're telling
stories about characters